[موسيقى]
من انا وصغيره كان على طول عندها حشريه
اللمس التكس كنا نعمل هالعجينه مع الطحين
بالبيت بتسلى
بحب اسمعوا
الهندسه مجال ما بقدر اتحكم فيه كرمال هيك
نقلت على
اكثر نحنا نشتغل نعمل
نشتغل باللاب ونحف خشب نشتغل بالحديد
فقررت تسافر على هولندا وهنيك عملت ماستيف
كونتاكتشيول ديزاين فكنا اشتغل بالريزين
بالليتك بالسيليكون
[موسيقى]
عملت مجموعه بازيت وبس رجعت ببيروت عملت
اول معرض لالي كانوا مع وفي منهم كانوا مع
جلد ومنهم مع ورق ذهب او مع خشب
بالقرنبيط عم بعمل قوالب فيهم قدرت اعمل
مثل لوحه كبيره فهيدا كان اول معرض لالي
بفوت فيه بمجال الفن بسرسوه ومن وقتها
القصص جرت بعدهم
كتير وقت لحتى اقرر انه انا ما عندي
اختيار معين او ما عندي تايتل واحد وكل
مره شغله بيجي بشكل او بفرن معينه اوقات
بصنع برودكت اوقات بصنعت
بس على طول فيه هالميل
معظم الوقت ما بعرف شو الريزولت
او بس تفشيله وبكتشر فانا بحب هالتشالنج
اللي هو انه جرب وما يزبط ولحديد ما
بالاخير يطلع معك شيء
الاكتشافات او كل
بيجوا من عالم مجهول ما بنتعلم شيء اذا
بدنا نعيد زيت الشي او نستعمل زيت الشي او
زيت المواد ما بنكتشف كثير
[موسيقى]
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات